This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Here at 99PI we are huge fans of the last archive. It's a show about the history of truth, how we know what we know, how we used to know things, and why it seems lately as if we don't know anything at all. The first three seasons were hosted by historian and author Jill LePore, who's a friend of the show and frequent guest, for their just launched fourth season, producer Ben Nottif-Haffrey has taken over hosting. There are stories about freelance wiretappers, time travel, and invasive species panics, with beautiful sound design that makes you feel like your inside of history itself. Today we're presenting the season premiere, which asks the question,
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。在 99PI，我们都是《最后的档案》的超级粉丝。这是一个关于真相历史的节目，讲述我们如何知道我们所知道的，我们过去是如何了解事物的，以及为什么最近看起来我们似乎什么也不知道。前三季由历史学家兼作家吉尔·莱波雷主持，她是本节目的朋友和常客；而在刚刚开播的第四季中，制作人本·诺蒂夫-哈弗里接替了主持工作。这里有关于自由职业窃听者、时间旅行和入侵物种恐慌的故事，并配有精美的声音设计，让你感觉自己正置身于历史本身。今天我们将为您呈现第四季的首播集，它提出了这样一个问题：
can machines automate creativity? And no, we're not talking about AI, we're talking about the player piano. I also love this episode so much because it features a personal favorite composer of mine, Raymond Scott, a guy whose music you have So let's step inside. The last archive. About 30 years ago, a man named Erwin Chuset encountered one of the strangest machines almost nobody had ever heard of. I was 40, I was broke, it was kind of a professional failure. Chuset was a DJ for a small community radio station in New Jersey.
机器能实现创造力的自动化吗？不，我们不是在谈论人工智能，我们谈的是自动钢琴。我也非常喜欢这一集，因为它聚焦了我个人最喜爱的作曲家之一雷蒙德·斯科特，他的音乐你一定听过。让我们走进其中。《最后的档案》。大约 30 年前，一个名叫欧文·丘西特的人偶然发现了一台几乎无人知晓的最奇怪的机器。我当时 40 岁，身无分文，遭遇了某种职业生涯的失败。丘西特是新泽西州一个小社区广播电台的 DJ。
A friend of his had put him on to a musician named Raymond Scott, one of the most famous musicians of the early 20th century, who had somehow been completely lost to history. These were records that were 25 cents a pop and used record stores back then, and they didn't even, they didn't even have them in a bin, they had them under the bins. Choose it loved Scott's music, and he began to get drawn into the mystery of it all.
他的一个朋友向他推荐了一位名叫雷蒙德·斯科特的音乐家，他是 20 世纪初最著名的音乐家之一，却不知为何完全湮没在了历史中。这些唱片在当时的二手唱片店里只卖 25 美分一张，而且它们甚至不在唱片架上，而是塞在唱片架底下。丘西特非常喜欢斯科特的音乐，并开始被其中的神秘感所吸引。
Who was this guy? He was obsessed, but his research kept dead ending. I went to a library and went looking through music history books and there's almost no mention of Raymond Scott. He wasn't in the jazz books, he wasn't in the classical books, he wasn't in the pop books. I was going to mystify he was kind of a mystery man. He was stuck until his friend found Scott in a phone book. He was still alive living in California. Jews had made a phone call and then he got on a plane and flew across the country.
这家伙到底是谁？他着迷了，但他的研究却屡屡陷入僵局。我去图书馆翻阅音乐历史书，几乎找不到对雷蒙德·斯科特的任何记载。爵士乐书里没有他，古典乐书里没有他，流行乐书里也没有他。我感到很迷惑，他简直是个神秘人物。他陷入了困境，直到他的朋友在电话簿里找到了斯科特。他还活着，住在加利福尼亚州。丘西特打了个电话，然后就坐上飞机飞越了整个国家。
By then Scott was in his 80s. He'd had a few strokes and he couldn't speak. He would rest in the back of a dingy old ranch house with the heat turned all the way up and a humidifier on full blast, so there was a kind of heavy fog all around. His wife was taking care of him, but she also kept a lot of stray animals. There was a dog with paralyzed hind legs dragging itself around, and a lifetime's worth of stuff piled everywhere. They were old rusted tape decks, they were wires, they were wheels of tape, they were
当时斯科特已经 80 多岁了。他中风过几次，已经无法说话。他躺在一间阴暗陈旧的牧场风格房屋的后方，暖气开到最大，加湿器开到最大档，周围弥漫着一层厚重的雾气。他的妻子在照顾他，但她也养了很多流浪动物。有一只后腿瘫痪的狗在地上拖着身子爬行，到处堆满了这辈子的杂物。有生锈的老旧录音机、电线、一盘盘的磁带，还有
tape decks, there were wires, there were reels of tape, there were 78 RPM discs, many of them broken, some of them on shelves, old magazines of electronic industry publications, parts catalogs, some of them dating back to the 1940s and 50s. I should say, this story, spooky as it is, it's kind of my dream. I'm Ben out of Half-Re and I've produced this podcast for the last few years, and I'm hosting a season of 6 episodes now, which, more on that later. All my life, I've written about history and made music. To find a secret hidden archive full of strange musical electronics, I can imagine almost nothing better.
录音机、电线、磁带盘、78 转黑胶唱片，许多都碎了，有些放在书架上，有电子行业出版物的旧杂志、零件目录，其中有些甚至可以追溯到 20 世纪 40 年代和 50 年代。我得说，这个故事虽然诡异，但某种程度上也是我的梦想。我是本·奥特-哈夫里，过去几年我一直在制作这个播客，现在我正在主持新的一季共 6 集节目，关于这个稍后再聊。我一生都在撰写历史和创作音乐。能找到一个藏有奇怪音乐电子设备的秘密隐藏档案，我简直想不出还有什么更好的了。
To know, through artifacts, what someone else once knew, something lost, because the records and papers and magazines that choose it found told a story. Scott had been one of the most famous musicians of the 20th century. He'd been on TV every week for a long time, in all the big magazines and films with movie stars. But almost nobody remembered him now. And I saw Raymond's entire life's work spread out between a leaky guest shed, a garage, some outbuildings on the property and van nides.
通过文物去了解某人曾经知晓的事物，那些失落的东西，因为丘西特找到的唱片、文件和杂志讲述了一个故事。斯科特曾是 20 世纪最著名的音乐家之一。很长一段时间里，他每周都会出现在电视上，登上所有大型杂志，并与电影明星一起拍电影。但现在几乎没有人记得他了。我看到雷蒙德一生的心血散落在漏水的客房小屋、车库、房产里的一些附属建筑以及范奈司。
How could somebody so famous be so forgotten? But something else didn't make sense either. There are all these old machines and tools strewn about with the rusty edges, and in the corner of the guest shed, covered in dust, chews it saw a huge hunk of metal encased in wood. Large dusty piece of furniture, a bit like a wooden console. of metal encased in wood. But it wasn't furniture. It was a heavy machine with wires spilling out, hundreds of switches on a black metal front, and wood paneling all around. It looked like the cockpit of an airplane, except that some of the switches and buttons
为什么一个如此著名的人会如此被人遗忘？但还有一件事也说不通。到处都散落着生锈边缘的旧机器和工具，在客房小屋的角落里，盖满灰尘，丘西特看到了一块用木头包裹着的巨大金属块。一件又大又满是灰尘的家具，有点像木质控制台。包裹在木头里的金属。但这并不是家具。这是一台沉重的机器，电线散落出来，黑色金属面板上有数百个开关，四周都是木质镶板。它看起来像飞机的驾驶舱，只不过有些开关和按钮
said things like record and power, and others said things like do-ah. I didn't know what it was. Later on, someone helping to sort through Scott's files found a contract. It was between Raymond Scott and Motown Records, and it detailed a binding, confidential agreement to build that machine that Shuse would be staring at. A machine that was meant to write songs. The Electronium.
上面写着诸如“录音”和“电源”之类的字眼，而另一些则写着诸如“do-ah”之类的字眼。我不知道那是什么。后来，一个帮忙整理斯科特档案的人发现了一份合同。那是雷蒙德·斯科特与摩城唱片公司签订的，详细说明了一项具有法律约束力的保密协议，旨在制造丘西特一直盯着看的那台机器。一台旨在谱写歌曲的机器。电子琴（Electronium）。
Shuse'd had come out to write songs. The Electronium. Choose it had come out to California because of these 25 cent records you've gotten obsessed with. It was honestly pretty random, but somehow he'd stumbled on one of the strangest stories in the history of technology. How did it work? That's the voice of Brian Ki-Hoo, one-time keyboardist for the who, Fiona Apple producer, Beatles Historem. And one of the people for whom this machine has become now a kind of holy grail. Because it makes no sense.
丘西特来到加州是为了写歌。电子琴。丘西特来到加州，是因为他迷上了这些 25 美分的唱片。老实说，这纯属偶然，但不知何故，他无意中发现了技术史上最奇怪的故事之一。它是如何运作的？那是布莱恩·基-胡的声音，他是谁乐队（The Who）的前键盘手、菲奥娜·苹果（Fiona Apple）的制作人、披头士历史学家。也是这台机器对他们来说已经成为某种圣杯的人之一。因为它完全说不通。
Raymond Scott began building this thing in the 1950s, and it was a kind of mechanical, early artificial intelligence that actually worked. We're freaked out about ChatGPT now. This thing was built in secret at a major studio in the 1970s. Michael Jackson used to watch it work. And nobody now can figure out how to get it to work again. In the years between Chusid stumbling upon the electronic and that rundown ranch house and today,
雷蒙德·斯科特在 20 世纪 50 年代开始制造这个东西，它是一种真正发挥作用的、机械式的早期人工智能。我们现在对 ChatGPT 感到恐慌。这东西是在 70 年代的一个大录音室里秘密制造的。迈克尔·杰克逊曾看着它工作。而现在没有人能弄清楚如何让它再次运转。在丘西特在那个简陋的牧场房子里偶然发现这台电子琴到今天的这些年里，
a lot of people have gotten involved in preserving the machine or bringing it back to life in some fashion. Brian Ki-Hoo, but also Mark Mother's Baw, the lead singer of Divo, Gatye, the pop star, and teams of engineers and programmers and musicians from all around the world. Because it turns out that the man behind it
很多人都参与进来了，或是为了保存这台机器，或是以某种方式让它重获新生。布莱恩·基-胡，还有迪沃乐队（Devo）的主唱马克·莫瑟斯鲍、流行歌星高黛（Gotye），以及来自世界各地的工程师、程序员和音乐家团队。因为事实证明，背后的这个人
knew how to make music like no one else, and they want to hear it again. Welcome to season 4 of The Last Archive. The show about how we know what we know, how we're used to know things, and why it seems sometimes lately is if we don't know anything at all. This episode is about that machine and its inventor, Raymond Scott. Not just because Scott is the most famous composer of the 20th century that most people have never heard of, but because I think his life traces one of the biggest stories about truth
懂得如何创作出独一无二的音乐，而他们想再次听到它。欢迎收看《最后的档案》第四季。这个节目探讨我们如何了解我们所知道的，我们过去是如何了解事物的，以及为什么最近有时感觉我们似乎什么也不知道。这一集是关于那台机器及其发明者雷蒙德·斯科特的。不仅因为斯科特是 20 世纪最著名却鲜为人知的作曲家，还因为我认为他的人生追溯了当今世界关于真相的最大故事之一。
in our world today. The attempt to define the difference between man and machine. and machine. Remarks before Harry sits down, he is now sitting down. There's another reason I want to spend some time with Scott. He is making himself comfortable. He recorded his whole life. And for them again, there he goes. Which made for some fun research.
试图界定人和机器之间的区别。以及机器。哈里坐下之前的发言，他现在正坐下。我还想花点时间了解斯科特的另一个原因。他正在让自己感到舒适。他记录了自己的整个人生。为了他们再次这样做，他去了。这为我们提供了一些有趣的研究素材。
Raymond Scott was born in Brooklyn in 1908. His parents named him Harry Warno. His father had sailed from Russia to New York two years earlier on a ship called America. Sometime after Scott was born, his parents bought a music store in Brooklyn, in Brownsville, a small Jewish neighborhood. They lived in the two floor apartment above their shop, surrounded by music and sound machines. Scott especially loved the phone. Sometimes he'd make prank calls.
雷蒙德·斯科特于 1908 年出生于布鲁克林。他的父母给他取名叫哈里·瓦尔诺。他的父亲两年前曾乘一艘名为“美利坚”号的船从俄罗斯来到纽约。斯科特出生后不久，他的父母在布鲁克林的布朗斯维尔（一个小型犹太人聚居区）买下了一家音乐商店。他们住在店上方两层的公寓里，周围环绕着音乐和发声机器。斯科特特别喜欢电话。有时他会恶作剧打电话。
Scott was growing up in an in-between time. A mishmash of the world we know now in the world of the 19th century. The electrified subway was brand new then. The year Scott was born, it had made its way out to Brooklyn, but the gas street lamps in Brownsville were still lit every night by a lamp lighter. There were chickens in the street, the smell of the sea out over Canarcy, candy shops and tenements, hot spiced corn beef and the delis, and briny half-sour pickles of the Jewish market, farms and saltwater.
斯科特的成长正值一个过渡时期。那是我们现在所知的世界与 19 世纪世界的结合体。电气化地铁当时还是新鲜事物。斯科特出生那年，它刚刚开通到布鲁克林，但布朗斯维尔的燃气路灯每天晚上仍然由点灯人点亮。街上有鸡，卡纳西方向飘来大海的气息，糖果店和筒子楼，熟食店里辛辣的热咸牛肉，犹太市场里咸味半酸的泡菜，农田和咸水。
It felt like the old country. It felt like the ends of the Earth. It was a, it was a like a little village. It felt like the ends of the earth. It was a, it was a like a little village. It was a neighborhood. Pearl's Imni Winters, one of the girls from the neighborhood. Later on, she and Scott got married and she's all over Scott's recordings. She's a, who never got over his obsession
感觉就像老家。感觉就像世界的尽头。它是一个，它就像一个小村庄。感觉就像世界的尽头。它是一个，它就像一个小村庄。它是一个社区。珀尔·伊姆尼·温特斯，邻里的女孩之一。后来，她和斯科特结婚了，斯科特的录音里到处都是她的身影。她是一个从未忘却对雷蒙德·斯科特痴迷的人，
with Raymond Scott, interviewed her with a colleague, just a little before she died. I used to go into the music store, you know, to buy music when I was a kid. with Raymond Scott, interviewed her with a colleague, just a little before she died. That music shop is where I think the dream of the songwriting machine began. It was a snapshot of everything that was changing in music in the early 1900s. For centuries, if you wanted to hear music in your house, someone in your family needed to know how to play. For a while, buying a song meant buying sheet music, bound together in little pamphlets.
在她去世前不久，他和一位同事采访了她。我小时候经常去音乐商店买音乐。对雷蒙德·斯科特的痴迷，在她去世前不久，他和一位同事采访了她。我认为，那家音乐店正是创作歌曲机器的梦想开始的地方。那是 20 世纪初音乐发生巨变的缩影。几个世纪以来，如果你想在家里听音乐，你家里的某个人就得懂得演奏。有一段时间，买一首歌意味着购买装订成小册子的乐谱。
But later in the 19th century, technologies that could capture and reproduce sound were invented. And by the start of the 20th century, mechanical music was taking off. Suddenly, you didn't need to know somebody who could play to listen to music. You could listen on records, whacksilliners, the radio. Scott was obsessed with these machines and the music that came out of them. He even started an amateur home radio station so he could make broadcasts from his bedroom to the living room. Even as a kid, he was always working on something. He dangled microphones out the window to record I mean, that's recording now. Oh my God, what a fact now. Even as a kid, he was always working on something. He'd angle microphones out the window
但在 19 世纪后期，能够捕捉和复制声音的技术被发明出来了。到了 20 世纪初，机械音乐开始腾飞。突然之间，你不需要认识会弹奏的人就能听音乐了。你可以通过唱片、蜡筒、收音机来收听。斯科特痴迷于这些机器以及从中流淌出的音乐。他甚至创办了一个业余的家庭广播电台，这样他就可以从自己的卧室向起居室进行广播。即使还是个孩子，他总是在捣鼓着什么。他把麦克风悬挂在窗外来录制——我的意思是，现在这叫录音。天哪，现在这算什么事实啊。即使还是个孩子，他总是在捣鼓着什么。他把麦克风悬挂在窗外
to record conversations on the street or the neighbor practicing piano. He would hang around the music shop with his dad, tinkering and watching not just how music was made, but how it was sold, what sold, and how it got reproduced. And there was one machine in particular that he became fascinated by. He told me that he taught himself to play the piano with the play of piano, and I guess that's how he first started.
来录制街上的对话或邻居练习钢琴的声音。他和父亲一起闲逛在音乐商店里，不仅琢磨和观察音乐是如何制作的，还观察它是如何销售的、什么好卖，以及它是如何被复制的。有一种机器尤其让他着迷。他告诉我，他是通过自动钢琴自学弹钢琴的，我想这就是他最初开始的方式。
The player piano. You've probably seen one before in a saloon in an old western. You know when someone gets shot, falls on the piano and it starts playing itself? That's a player piano. A piano that plays is if there were a ghost of the keyboard. Songs were sold as scrolls of paper with little holes punched out for each note, a set of mechanical instructions for the piano. The result?
自动钢琴。你可能在老西部片的酒吧里见过这种钢琴。你知道当有人中枪倒在钢琴上，然后钢琴自己开始演奏的时候吗？那就是自动钢琴。一台会自动弹奏的钢琴，就好像键盘后面有个幽灵一样。歌曲以纸卷的形式出售，每个音符都打上了小孔，这是一组给钢琴的机械指令。结果呢？
You could hear nearly any song in your home, even if you had no idea how to play it yourself. Scott loved the piano in the shop. He'd take a role and probably play it as slowly as possible, fitting his little fingers to the keys as they press themselves down, learning by machine. Most people these days think of the player piano as a novelty or gimmick. But I want to spend a minute with it here, because it's a big part, not just of music history, but of automation history. We tend to think of automation as man vs robot, factory lines and coal mines, but the player
你可以在家里听到几乎任何一首歌，即使你自己根本不知道怎么弹。斯科特很喜欢店里的那台钢琴。他会拿出一个纸卷，尽可能慢地弹奏，让他的小手指按压着自动下沉的琴键，通过机器进行学习。如今，大多数人认为自动钢琴只是一种新奇玩意儿或噱头。但我在这里想花点时间讲讲它，因为它不仅是音乐史的重要组成部分，也是自动化历史的重要组成部分。我们往往认为自动化是人与机器人的对立、工厂流水线和煤矿，但自动钢琴
piano was a kind of robot too, one we often forget about, but an early, massively influential one, that foreshadowed so much of what was to come. When Scott was a kid, people thought the player piano would be the future of music. There were hundreds of thousands of them sold each year, and millions of song rolls. By 1919, when Scott was 11, there were more player pianos being sold than regular pianos. It wasn't just sales though. Copyright laws in the United States were built around the player piano and the record player in equal part. You can draw a straight line from player
其实也是一种机器人，一种我们经常忘记的机器人，但它却是一个早期且影响深远的机器人，预示了未来将要发生的许多事情。斯科特小时候，人们认为自动钢琴将是音乐的未来。每年售出几十万台自动钢琴和数百万首歌曲纸卷。到 1919 年斯科特 11 岁时，自动钢琴的销量已经超过了普通钢琴。不过不仅仅是销量。美国的版权法在同等程度上围绕着自动钢琴和留声机建立。你可以画一条直线，从自动钢琴纸卷连到
piano rolls to punch cards and the first computer programs. And people made all kinds of player pianos. What you're listening to now is a special kind of player piano role that could capture all the subtleties of human performance. This one was recorded by the composer WC and reproduced decades after his death by machine. That's what Scott was learning in his family's music shop, Role by Role. Not just to play like a machine, but to wonder at all the magical things machines suddenly could do. When I was trying to understand how Scott grew up, I read up on his neighborhood, and in
打孔卡片和第一代计算机程序。人们制作了各种各样的自动钢琴。你现在听到的是一种特殊的自动钢琴纸卷，它可以捕捉人类演奏的所有微妙之处。这一卷是由作曲家德彪西录制的，并在他去世几十年后由机器复制出来。这就是斯科特在家族音乐店里卷起一卷卷学到的东西。不仅仅是像机器一样弹奏，更是惊叹于机器突然能够做出的所有神奇事情。当我试图理解斯科特的成长经历时，我阅读了关于他所在社区的资料，在
one memoir, I found a particular detail that snapped it all into view. The drugstore just down the street from Scott had a poster in the window. It was titled The Human Factory, and it imagined a person as if they were a kind of complex machine with all these little engineers inside. Scott must have passed that poster plenty of times. He had dreams of becoming like a machine himself, attaching motors to his hands so he could play the piano faster, the kind of way only a player piano could. Everywhere, that line between man and machine was beginning to blur.
一本回忆录中，我发现了一个让一切豁然开朗的特定细节。斯科特家街角的那家药房的橱窗里贴着一张海报。它名为《人类工厂》，将人想象成一台复杂的机器，里面有所有这些小工程师。斯科特一定经过那张海报很多次。他梦想着自己也能像机器一样，给双手装上马达，这样他就能像只有自动钢琴才能做到的那样，弹奏得更快。到处都是，人与机器之间的界限开始变得模糊。
But there was one place where the difference was unmistakable. The machine never made mistakes. The song sounded the same every single time. And to Scott, that was the ideal. The struggle between being a musician and an engineer was very real for him. He just loved equipment. Mark was the one insistent that he go to Riyadh.
但在一个地方，差异是毋庸置疑的。机器从不犯错。每一次弹奏出的歌曲都一模一样。对斯科特来说，这就是理想状态。音乐家与工程师之间的挣扎对她来说非常真实。他就是热爱设备。马克坚持要他去利雅得。
I don't think he wanted to. That choice, music Music or engineering. It's set the course for Scott's entire life, because Scott never could give up on engineering. But his brother, who was a rising star in music, saw that he had a gift for composing that almost no one else did. He got Scott a job as the pianist
我想他并不想去。这种选择，音乐还是工程学。它为斯科特的一生奠定了基调，因为斯科特永远无法放弃工程学。但他的哥哥在音乐界正在崭露头角，他看出斯科特有着几乎无人能及的作曲天赋。他帮斯科特争取到了 CBS 广播管弦乐团钢琴师的工作，
for the CBS radio orchestra, and immediately Scott began to get noticed. He was anxious that people would think he only had the job because of his brother, so Harry Warno flipped through the phone book to Lee found a name he liked, Raymond Scott. A name he also chose because it sounded less Jewish, and he was always anxious about that. He played his piano, he wrote his songs, and he kept his engineering passion more as a hobby. CBS was a good situation, except for one thing. He was always playing standards, songs that people knew they liked and had heard a million
斯科特立刻开始受到关注。他担心别人会认为他得到这份工作全靠他哥哥，于是哈里·瓦尔诺翻阅电话簿，直到找到一个他喜欢的名字——雷蒙德·斯科特。他选择这个名字也是因为听起来没那么像犹太人，而他一直对此感到焦虑。他弹钢琴，写歌，把对工程的热情更多地当作一种业余爱好。CBS 的环境不错，除了一点。他总是演奏标准曲目，也就是人们知道自己喜欢并且已经听过无数遍的歌曲。
times already. He said that he wanted to write music that people would like the first time they heard it. He asked his brother Mark if he could put together a band. He wanted to put together a six piece band with himself in it. Mark said yes. Scott started hunting for five musicians
他说，他想写那种人们一听就喜欢的音乐。他问哥哥马克能不能组建一支乐队。他想组建一个六人乐队，自己也是其中一员。马克同意了。斯科特开始物色五位音乐家，
who could do exactly what he wanted. What he wanted was music with a spark that could form a connection with a listener immediately out of nowhere. He had a couple songs ready, so he found his guys rehearsed, and then he got an audience together in CBS's Studio B. They dimmed the lights all the way, and they began to play. A journalist wrote about it a year later. Nobody who attended that premiere 18 months ago was likely to forget it. Out of the darkness, there came a thin, wailing note, barely masking a slow, suggestive thumping
让他们能完全按他的要求去做。他想要的音乐带有某种火花，能够瞬间与听众建立连接，仿佛凭空出现。他准备了几首歌，找到了他的人员进行排练，然后在 CBS 的 B 录音室召集了一群观众。他们把灯光调得极暗，然后开始演奏。一年后，一位记者对此进行了报道。18 个月前参加那场首映式的任何人都不大可能会忘记它。黑暗中，传出一个纤细、哀怨的音符，勉强掩盖了鼓点缓慢、暗示性的敲击。
on the drums. When it was over, the audience rose to its feet and cheered, the fan mail poured in. Who was this man's god? Where was he from? Where had he been all these years? They created such a...generated, such an amazing listener reaction that they immediately got a recording contract with the master label, which was owned by Irving Mills, who was Duke Ellington's manager. The response was unprecedented.
当演奏结束时，观众起立欢呼，粉丝来信如雪花般飞来。这个上帝是谁？他来自哪里？这些年他都在哪儿？他们创造了……引发了如此惊人的听众反响，以至于他们立即与 Master 唱片公司签下了唱片合约，该公司由公爵·埃灵顿的经纪人欧文·米尔斯（Irving Mills）所有。这种反响是史无前例的。
In a minute, I'm going to take you right on in, but we're going to have a very entertaining visit with one of the year's sensational musical groups only get in there. Scott was trying to sell a perfect musical package. He said he went out to clubs to track which tempos made people get up and dance. He had a whole thing about names. He called his band of six people, a quintet, not a sex tip. He even renamed his saxophone player. And he is the youngest of all groups.
过一会儿，我将带你们直接进去，但我们将对今年轰动一时的音乐团体之一进行一次非常有趣的拜访，只要能进去就行。斯科特试图出售一个完美的音乐套餐。他说他去俱乐部追踪哪种节奏能让人起身跳舞。他有一整套关于名字的想法。他管自己这支六人乐队叫五重奏（quintet），而不是六重奏（sextet）。他甚至给他的萨克斯手改了名字。他是所有乐队中最年轻的。
His name was originally Dave Harris, but now it's Eric Tullet. Eric Tullet, very much an interesting name. Yeah, that's very much the idea of a name. He wouldn't write his music down. He'd just play it at the piano for his quintet, and then have them play their parts back to like a do-it-right. Note for note. And we call the fellow that marvelous years and memories. They never forget a composition
他的名字原本叫戴夫·哈里斯（Dave Harris），但现在叫埃里克·图莱特（Eric Tullet）。埃里克·图莱特，非常有趣的名字。对，这非常符合名字的概念。他不会把音乐写下来。他只是在钢琴上为他的五重奏弹奏，然后让他们把各自的部分像……一样弹回来。一个音符都不差。我们称这位了不起的伙伴为充满岁月与回忆的人。他们从不忘记自己发现的乐曲。
when they find it. Once they had it down, it rarely changed. And that was just how Scott wanted it. If he could have replaced each of his musician's minds with a swirl of music, he probably would have. He didn't know how to handle human relationships too well. They called him a bully. They called him a b well. They called him a bully. They called him something. Bastard. They called him all kinds of names, because he was trying
一旦他们掌握了，就很少再改变。这正是斯科特想要的。如果他能用一阵旋律替换掉每个音乐家的头脑，他大概会这么做。他不太懂得如何处理人际关系。他们叫他暴君。他们叫他 b 某某。他们叫他暴君。他们叫他各种各样的外号，因为他试图
to make them play better. One of his musicians once said, nobody worked with Raymond. Everybody worked under Raymond. Johnny Williams, the drummer, said, we hated every minute of it because we were being told what to play. He said at the same time that we hated it, we were making more money than anybody in town. The music was like jazz, but without the improvisation or the looseness, tightly managed, the price of mechanical perfection.
让他们表现得更好。他的一个音乐家曾说，没有人是和雷蒙德一起工作的。所有人都是在雷蒙德手下干活。鼓手约翰尼·威廉姆斯说，我们讨厌每一分钟，因为我们被告知该弹什么。他说，尽管我们讨厌它，但我们赚的钱比城里任何人都要多。这种音乐就像爵士乐，但没有即兴发挥或松散感，管理得极其严格，这是机械完美的代价。
I want to pay again for my career. He rehearsed... I want to cut that problem in his face. And he rehearsed? I keep on cutting clean the hands of the clock. He rehearsed. He wasn on cutting clean the empty cup. He rehearsed. He put him getting active at the same time.
我想再次为我的职业生涯付出代价。他排练……我想解决他脸上的那个问题。他排练？我一直在利落地剪断时钟的指针。他排练。他当时正利落地剪掉那个空杯子。他排练。他在同一时间让自己变得活跃起来。
He looked that way without pushing him out of the way. He was driving his musicians crazy, because they would say nobody needs to rehearse this much. Scott held his musicians to an impossible standard. He wanted them to play like machines, but it's hard to argue with the results. His rise was stratospheric. Stravinsky, cab Calloway, Duke Ellington, they were all Raymond Scott fans.
他看着那个方向，却没有把他推开。他快把他的音乐家们逼疯了，因为他们会说根本不需要排练这么多次。斯科特对音乐家的要求达到了不可思议的地步。他想让他们像机器一样演奏，但结果很难让人反驳。他的崛起速度堪称火箭式。斯特拉文斯基、卡布·卡洛韦、公爵·埃灵顿，他们全都是雷蒙德·斯科特的粉丝。
In the 1940s, he had his own radio show, The Raymond Scotchow. He became the music director of CBS Radio, where he led a racially integrated radio orchestra. This I think not because he was especially progressive, but because all he cared about was the music. This, in so many ways, explains why he was working with machines like life. Oh, yeah. Right, that musician.
在 20 世纪 40 年代，他有了自己的广播节目《雷蒙德·斯科特秀》。他成为了 CBS 广播电台的音乐总监，并在那里领导了一支种族融合的广播管弦乐团。我认为这并不是因为他特别激进，而是因为他关心的只有音乐。这在很多方面解释了为什么他一生都在与机器打交道。哦，对。没错，那个音乐家。
That was his best friend. The machines were his best friends. To me, when I heard this story, I kept thinking about Scott as a kid at the player piano. When that machine was invented, it scared people. Two years before Raymond Scott was born, John Philip Susa, the famous composer, wrote an essay called The Menace of Mechanical Music. The whole course of music has been the expression of soul states, he wrote. And now in this 20th century come these talking and playing machines to reduce the expression to a mathematical system of megaphones, wheels, cogs, discs, cylinders, and all manner
那是他最好的朋友。机器就是他最好的朋友。对我说，当我听到这个故事时，我一直想到斯科特小时候在自动钢琴旁的场景。当那台机器被发明出来时，它吓坏了人们。在雷蒙德·斯科特出生前两年，著名作曲家约翰·菲利普·苏萨（John Philip Susa）写了一篇名为《机械音乐的威胁》的文章。他写道，音乐的整个历程一直是灵魂状态的表达。而在 20 世纪，这些会说话和演奏的机器出现了，将这种表达贬低为由扩音器、轮子、齿轮、圆盘、圆筒和各种旋转物组成的数学系统。
of revolving things. The player piano became a dark symbol of modern life. When Kurt Vonnegut wrote his first novel about a dystopian America run by engineers in their automatic machinery, he called it player piano. By the time Raymond Scott was getting famous, those fears about mechanical music were everywhere. Same story everywhere. New machines, high speed production, fewer jobs, and ten men for every job it can be had. Scott was fighting a classic battle, mechanical perfection against human error.
自动钢琴成了现代生活的一个黑暗象征。当库尔特·冯内古特写他的第一部小说，讲述一个由工程师及其自动化机器统治的反乌托邦美国时，他将其命名为《自动钢琴》。到雷蒙德·斯科特开始成名时，对机械音乐的恐惧随处可见。到处都是同样的故事。新机器，高速生产，工作岗位减少，每一个能找到的工作岗位都有十个人在争抢。斯科特在进行一场经典的战斗——机械完美对抗人为失误。
What was at stake were free will, agency, the human soul. That conflict was one of the main rhythms of 20th century history, and Scott was like a leading melody. And then, he hit a wrong note. That story, after the break. In the 1940s, Raymond Scott was properly famous. He and his wife Pearl packed up their kids in his equipment and moved to a big house out in Tuckahoe, New York.
危在旦夕的是自由意志、能动性、人类的灵魂。这种冲突是 20.世纪历史的主旋律之一，而斯科特就像是其中的主旋律。然后，他弹错了一个音符。那个故事，中场休息后继续。在 20 世纪 40 年代，雷蒙德·斯科特已经真正出名了。他和妻子珀尔把孩子和设备打包好，搬到了纽约州塔卡霍的一栋大房子里。
He had a wonderful apartment and study, but we moved from there, because he was a ham radio operator. He wanted to be where he'd have good reception. I kind of love that. He finally had enough money to buy a big house, but actually the only reason he was moving out of the city was so that he could have better ham radio reception. He was tinkering with his machines again. Not just microphones and high-fi equipment, but new sorts of instruments. Problem was, electronics was not a casual hobby in the late 1930s and early 40s. He saw an electronic parts catalog and he wanted to order every part in the catalog. Stan Warno is Raymond Scott and Pearl's Emny Wintersson. He made a great documentary about
他有一间极好的公寓和书房，但我们从那里搬走了，因为他是一名业余无线电爱好者。他想去一个能有良好接收效果的地方。我有点喜欢这一点。他终于有足够的钱买一栋大房子了，但实际上他搬出市区的唯一原因是为了获得更好的业余无线电接收效果。他又在鼓捣他的机器了。不仅是麦克风和高保真设备，还有各种新乐器。问题是，在 20 世纪 30 年代末和 40 年代初，电子学可不是什么随意的爱好。他看到了一份电子零件目录，想要订购目录里的每一个零件。斯坦·瓦尔诺是雷蒙德·斯科特和珀尔·伊姆尼·温特斯的儿子。他拍了一部关于他父亲的出色纪录片，名叫《解构老爸》。我去年冬天去拜访了他。
his father called Deconstructing dad. I visited him last winter And he thought the only way he's gonna make enough money to do that is to form a big band and so he did form a big band I went out on the road It's more 30 in New York and time for CBS to present the Raymond Scotch show Across the continent and later to the whole world by shortwave come song hits of the day Starring America's number one composer with a band In the 1930s, Scots hit seemed to have been about the music first, but in the 40s, his focus seems to have shifted from writing great songs to making as much money from his music as possible so he could fuel his mechanical hobby. He was like his own version of his dad's music shop.
他认为自己能赚到足够钱做这件事的唯一方法就是组建一个大乐队，于是他确实组建了一个大乐队。我开始在路上巡演。纽约时间上午 3 点半，CBS 迎来呈现《雷蒙德·斯科特秀》的时刻。跨越整个大陆，随后通过短波传向全世界，这里有当天的热门歌曲，由全美第一作曲家领衔的乐队……在 20 世纪 30 年代，斯科特的走红似乎首先是为了音乐，但在 40 年代，他的重心似乎从创作伟大的歌曲转移到了从音乐中赚取尽可能多的钱，好为他的机械爱好提供资金。他就像是他父亲音乐店的自己版本。
Music sold any way you like, but a big band needed a singer. He was always churning through them, always on the lookout for someone perfect. And that's how he met Marjorie Chandler. We went to Chicago and we took an apartment there. Scott heard through one of the band's managers that there was a young girl from Canada he should meet. She'd sung in a big radio contest in one first place. She was about 13 years old and her voice was amazing.
音乐以你喜欢的任何方式出售，但大乐队需要一个歌手。他一直在不停地更换歌手，总是在寻找完美的人选。这就是他遇到玛乔丽·钱德勒（Marjorie Chandler）的方式。我们去了芝加哥，在那里租了一套公寓。斯科特通过乐队的一位经纪人听说，加拿大有个年轻女孩他应该见见。她在一次大型广播比赛中获得了一等奖。她大约 13 岁，嗓音惊为天人。
Scott decided to take her on as a student, full time. He thought she had real potential, and so she came to live with us. Marjory's family sent her to live at the house in Tukaho. According to Pearl, she and Scott were like surrogate parents, except Scott and Marjory spent endless hours practicing. It was like with his quintet, except Chandler was a kid, away from her parents. This tape is likely from later I don't even know what you're saying. You think coughs are better. I think it's a heart.
斯科特决定全职收她为学生。他认为她很有潜力，于是她搬来和我们一起住。玛乔丽的家人把她送到塔卡霍的房子里生活。据珀尔说，她和斯科特就像代理父母一样，只不过斯科特和玛乔丽花无数个小时练习。这和他的五重奏一样，只不过钱德勒还是个孩子，远离了父母。这段录音很可能是后来录的……我甚至不知道你在说什么。你觉得咳嗽好点了吗。我觉得这是心。
You know, I'm okay. I'm okay. Scott gave her a new name, Dorothy Collins. She'd go to school. She'd wander around the big house and write her name, Marjorie, over and over again. Then she'd go back to practicing. It was a backbreaking regimen, but she was an incredible talent. And as she got older and better, she began featuring her in his band.
你知道的，我没事。我没事。斯科特给她取了个新名字——多萝西·柯林斯（Dorothy Collins）。她要去上学。她会在大房子里四处闲逛，一遍又一遍地写下她的名字“玛乔丽”。然后她会回去继续练习。这是一套极其残酷的训练方案，但她有着令人难以置信的天赋。随着她年龄的增长和技艺的提高，他开始让她在自己的乐队中亮相。
She grew up with the family. When she was a bit older, she sang with the band for the first time on the air. After Scott started hosting the Lucky Strike Hit Parade, a popular TV show, she became the featured singer. She was 24. And at some point along the way, they got romantically involved. And then I have seen some letters
她和这个家庭一起长大。大一点后，她第一次随乐队在电台唱歌。斯科特开始主持热门电视节目《好彩运热门大游行》（The Lucky Strike Hit Parade）后，她成为了特色歌手。她 24 岁了。在这一过程中的某个时候，他们发展出了浪漫关系。然后我看到了一些信件，
where my mother was writing to him saying, it's really I'm not really comfortable with her and who knows what was going on because again that they eventually got involved with each other and he divorced my mom and married her. Scott and Marjorie, now Dorothy Collins, were married when she was 25. I don't want to dramatize this or speculate on how and when they got together, because no matter what, it's a dark turn. She had been like an adopted daughter to them
我母亲在信里对他说，我真的……我跟她在一起真的不太舒服，谁知道当时发生了什么，因为话说回来，他们最终还是在一起了，他跟我妈妈离婚并娶了她。斯科特和玛乔丽——现在叫多萝西·柯林斯——在她 25 岁时结婚了。我不想把这件事戏剧化，也不想去推测他们是如何以及何时走到一起的，因为无论如何，这都是一个黑暗的转折。对于他们来说，她曾像一个被收养的女儿一样，远离了自己的父母。
away from her own parents. It was the culmination, I think, of the most dangerous strain in Scott's thinking about musicians and people. What he must have seen in Marjorie Chandler in the beginning was Dorothy Collins, the chance to make his own musician, his own person, as if he were building a machine. Every week they appeared on TV together. Collins became a kind of American darling, achieving a level of celebrity he even Scott had never had,
我认为，这是斯科特关于音乐家和人的思考中最危险倾向的顶峰。他最初在玛乔丽·钱德勒身上看到的必定是多萝西·柯林斯，一个创造属于自己的音乐家、创造属于自己的个人的机会，就好像他在建造一台机器一样。他们每周一起出现在电视上。柯林斯成了一种美国甜心，达到了连斯科特本人也从未企及的名人高度，
a star. The money came pouring in. They moved into a mansion on Long Island. It had 32 rooms and four stories. That's Deb Studebaker, Raymond Scott and Dorothy Collins' daughter. She's a teacher and a poet, which you can hear by the way she describes her childhood home. The house was at the end of a long gravel driveway. It had a forest behind it. It was very grand. There was a library with a secret door, you pull it out, there was a bathroom behind it.
一颗明星。金钱源源不断地涌入。他们搬进了长岛的一座豪宅。它有 32 个房间和四层楼。那是黛布·斯图贝克（Deb Studebaker），雷蒙德·斯科特和多萝西·柯林斯的女儿。她是一名教师和诗人，你可以从她描述童年住所的方式中听出来。房子在一长条碎石车道的尽头。后面有一片森林。非常宏伟。有一个带秘密门的图书馆，你把门拉开，后面是一个浴室。
We would go on these explorations in the forest. There was wisteria hanging over an archway that was always filled with bees. Inside the house, Scott had begun to amass all the electronic parts he wanted. He was at one secretive and proud to show it off. Let me take you downstairs and show you these technical facilities and I take it we're supposed to have home maybe a half million separate items I saw an electronic music studio wants to grow and grow and grow and grow. The room was full of gear switches meters welders of furnace. But now I'd like to take upstairs to show you what we've been building with all this equipment.
我们会在森林里进行这些探险。一个拱门上挂满了紫藤花，总是挤满了蜜蜂。在屋里，斯科特开始囤积他想要的各种电子零件。他既保密又为之骄傲，急于向人展示。让我带你下楼去看看这些技术设施，我想我们大概有半百万个不同的零件。我看到一个电子音乐室在不断成长、成长、成长、成长。房间里挤满了齿轮、开关、仪表、焊机、炉子。但现在我想带你上楼去看看我们用所有这些设备建造了什么。
Upstairs was a 30-foot wall of obscure electronic musical machinery. Alongside his other musical work, Scott had begun writing and recording music for commercials. I have for several months now been unable to get this jingle for sprite out of my head. Over the course of the 1950s, Scott wrote jingles for a lot of big companies, Schlitz Beer, RCA Victor, Vicks Ford Chrysler, and a lot of the time it was Dorothy Collins singing them. He had a plaque over his piano at that red, ideally the word should make sense. These companies were selling the future, and they needed a sound to match it. In the 1950s, Americans were drunk on the post-war promise of consumer technology. It was the age of automatic, of being able to buy all sorts of machines that would make
楼上是一面 30 英尺长的晦涩电子音乐机器墙。除了其他音乐工作外，斯科特还开始为商业广告谱写和录制音乐。过去几个月里，我脑海里一直挥之不去这个雪碧的广告歌。在 20 世纪 50 年代期间，斯科特为许多大公司写过广告歌，比如施利兹啤酒（Schlitz Beer）、RCA 维克多、Vicks、福特、克莱斯勒，而且很多时候都是多萝西·柯林斯在演唱。他的钢琴上方挂着一块牌匾，上面写着：理想情况下，词义应当合理。这些公司在出售未来，他们需要与之相匹配的声音。在 20 世纪 50 年代，美国人沉醉于战后消费技术的承诺之中。这是一个自动化的时代，能够购买各种让生活更轻松的机器。
your life easier. To make reality of imagination, this is Bendix, the Tomorrow People. Scott and Collins seemed at the time to have a happy life together as the Tomorrow People, throwing parties at their mansion, making music in the machine rooms and listening to it in the listening room. They were in many ways the sound of that post-war dream world. They made music meant to push the button that sent consumers marching off to make a purchase. During those years, Scott was creating the kinds of machines his music helped to sell, whirling spinning devices that seemed as if they came from the future.
将想象变为现实，这就是本迪克斯（Bendix），明天的人们。当时的斯科特和柯林斯看起来过着幸福的生活，作为“明天的人们”，在他们的豪宅里举办派对，在机器室里创作音乐，在视听室里聆听音乐。在许多方面，他们就是那个战后梦想世界的合声。他们制作音乐的目的是按下那个让消费者大举外出购物的按钮。在那几年里，斯科特一直在创造他的音乐曾帮忙推销的那类机器，那些旋转飞舞的装置，看起来仿佛来自未来。
Just keep in mind how different what you're hearing is from popular music in the 50s. I mean, this was the top song of 1959. With iron icons and the British kept becoming, there wasn't as many as there was a while ago. With iron once slower and they begin to run it, on down the Mississippi to the Gulf of Mexico. Music like Scots just didn't exist in the mainstream, but he was sneaking it in there through commercials. He saw his machines as a way to push the envelope, and thought that because the sounds they made were new, they'd catch the ear and away jingles made with old instruments couldn't.
请记住，你现在听到的音乐与 50 年代的流行音乐有多么不同。我的意思是，这是 1959 年的顶级歌曲。随着铁图标和英国不断涌现，数量已经不如前一阵子了。伴随着更缓慢的钢铁声，他们开始顺着密西西比河运行，一直开到墨西哥湾。像斯科特这样的音乐在主流中根本不存在，但他通过商业广告将其偷偷塞了进去。他将自己的机器视为一种突破常规的方式，并认为由于它们发出的声音是崭新的，它们会吸引人们的注意，这是用旧乐器制作的广告歌无法做到的。
Scots seems to have created one of the first, if not the first, musical sequencer. A device that is the foundation for much of modern pop. In a weird historical twist, one of the ways he had financed all this experimentation was by selling his early hits to Warner Brothers, where they became a lot of the music soundtracking the loony tunes. Literally, this man put the tunes in loony tunes. But then he started to get sick. His brother and his father had died of heart disease, and Scott had his first heart attack in 1958.
斯科特似乎创造了最早的音乐音序器之一，即使不是第一个。一种构成了现代流行音乐大部分基础的装置。在历史命运的一个奇异转折中，他资助所有这些实验的方法之一，是将他早期的热门歌曲卖给了华纳兄弟，这些歌曲后来成为了许多《乐一通》（Looney Tunes）动画片的配乐。字面意义上，这个人把曲子写进了《乐一通》。但随后他开始生病。他的哥哥和父亲都死于心脏病，斯科特在 1958 年迎来了他的第一次心脏病发作。
I don't think it's a coincidence that within a year he began to work on the first version of the electronic him, his songwriting machine. I remember him telling me, you know, about this machine. I'm working on a machine that's going to compose and perform at the same time. This was the stuff of science fiction. A dream a few people had had, but nobody went for it quite like Scott. A machine, not just for playing music, but for composing it.
我认为这绝非巧合，在一年之内，他就开始着手研发第一版的电子琴——他的歌曲创作机器。我记得他跟我谈过这台机器。我正在研发一台能够同时进行创作和表演的机器。这简直是科幻小说里的东西。这是少数人曾有过的梦想，但没有人像斯科特那样全身心投入。一台不仅能演奏音乐，还能创作音乐的机器。
Scott began to work harder and harder on a machine, not just for playing music, but for composing it. Scott began to work harder and harder on the machine, and at the same time, his marriage to Dorothy Collins unraveled. She's discovered that she loved acting and the theater, and my dad didn't travel with her or us. He was always working on his own stuff, but I think there was a certain lightness, I think, that she probably found being
斯科特开始更加努力地研发这台机器，与此同时，他和多萝西·柯林斯的婚姻也破裂了。她发现自己热爱表演和戏剧，而我父亲没有和她或我们一起旅行。他总是在忙自己的事情，但我认为她可能在其中找到了一种轻松感，因为她现在因某种属于她自己的新事物而受到尊重。表演是属于她自己的。这与他毫无关系。柯林斯离开了，随后他们离婚了。她在法庭上作证说，他是一个完美主义者，批评极其严厉，以至于把她逼出了哮喘，当他在场时她甚至无法唱歌。我母亲常说，这就好比弗兰肯斯坦的怪物，而那个怪物某种程度上醒来后决定……
respected now, you know, for something new that was hers. Acting was hers. He had nothing to do with that. Collins left, and then they were divorced. She testified in court that he was such a perfectionist, so intensely critical that he gave her asthma, and she couldn't sing when he was around. It's my mother used to say it was like Frankenstein's monster and the monster kind of woke up and decided, you know,
她现在因属于她自己的全新成就而备受尊敬，你知道的。表演是她自己的事，与他毫无关系。柯林斯离开后，他们就离婚了。她在法庭上作证说，他是个十足的完美主义者，极其苛刻，甚至让她得了哮喘，而且他在场时她根本无法唱歌。这就像我母亲常说的，就像弗兰肯斯坦的怪物一样，这个怪物某种程度上醒来后决定，你懂的，
that she could be her own person. But Scott was bereft, and he took a bunch of sleeping pills, thinking he was going to kill himself, but he just went to sleep for a long time. He moved out of the house into an industrial space, in a big office park on Long Island. His TV show was off the air. He didn't have a hit band anymore, and he was alone. But he had one thing left, the electronic. I have very clear memories of being out there and the electronic was in the very next
这样她就能做真正的自己了。但斯科特悲痛欲绝，他吞了一大把安眠药，以为自己会死掉，结果只是睡了很久。他搬出了家，搬到了长岛一个大型办公园区里的工业场所。他的电视节目停播了。他不再有热门乐队了，而且孤身一人。但他还剩下一件东西，那就是电子琴。我有非常清晰的记忆，当时我在外面，而电子琴就在隔壁
room iterating away, which is what it did. You had to kind of set it up up and then it would go through these iterations We would be listening to it and he would hear something he really liked and he jumped off and go in there and record it on the cassette In the 1960s Raymond Scott was living in a long low-light cement warehouse surrounded by machines He had to seriously downgrade his life. Jeff winner. He works with Chuse that radio DJ who went out to visit Scott. And together with Scott's family, they're preserving, managing, and sharing his archives.
房间里不断地迭代运行，这就是它的工作方式。你得先把参数设置好，然后它就会进行各种迭代。我们会听着它运行，当他听到特别喜欢的音段时，就会跳起来跑进去，用卡带把它录下来。20世纪60年代，雷蒙德·斯科特住在长岛一个低矮、阴暗的水泥仓库里，周围都是机器。他的生活质量急剧下降。杰夫·威纳（Jeff Winner）说道。他曾与去拜访斯科特的电台DJ丘斯合作。他和斯科特的家人一起，负责保存、管理和分享斯科特的档案。
He went from a massive mansion of his own design to living on Long Island in a warehouse that wasn't even zoned for residential. That didn't have a kitchen who was not supposed to be living there. He'd gotten married for the third time to a woman named Mitsy Curtis. And this time it stuck, but money was tight. Popular music was moving on. He was still composing the occasional jingle, but now really it was all machines and not just in his warehouse. He was still composing the occasional jingle, but now really it was all machines.
他从自己设计的一座宏伟豪宅，搬到了长岛的一个仓库里，这个仓库甚至没有住宅用地规划。里面没有厨房，本不应该在那里住人生。他第三次结婚，娶了一个名叫米西·柯蒂斯（Mitsy Curtis）的女人。这一次婚姻维持了下来，但手头很紧。流行音乐正在向前发展。他偶尔还会创作一些商业广告歌，但现在一切都变成了机器，不仅在仓库里是这样。他偶尔还会创作一些商业广告歌，但现在一切都变成了机器。
And not just in his warehouse. The concern over automation was reaching a fever pitch in the United States. In 1960, John F. Kennedy even ran for president against the machine threat. Because the problem that West Virginia is facing is the problem that all America is going to face. That is the problem of what happens to men when machines take their place. Meanwhile, Raymond Scott seems to have been trying to replace as much of himself as possible with machine. Everything he had ever done up into that point in one way or another would become part of Electronium.
而且不仅是在他的仓库里。美国对自动化的担忧已经达到了狂热的程度。1960年，约翰·F·肯尼迪甚至以应对机器威胁为竞选纲领竞选总统。因为西弗吉尼亚州面临的问题，也就是全美国即将面临的问题。这就是当机器取代人类时，人类会面临什么的问题。与此同时，雷蒙德·斯科特似乎一直在试图用机器尽可能多地替换他自己。他在此之前所做的一切，以这样或那样的方式，都将成为“电子琴”（Electronium）的一部分。
Even if he hadn't even declared to himself that that was his goal yet. It's like everything's under that one roof. His baseline generator, his drum pattern generator, the melody sequencer, all of it tied together with thick wires hidden behind the concrete walls of the factory. And when Raymond came to the door, the first thing I encountered was, well, I want you to write a sign this disclosure agreement. Tom Ray. He used to work at Moog, probably the most famous synthesizer company of all time. He's taught electronic music history at the Berkeley College of Music, where he was a professor. But at the
哪怕他当时甚至还没有向自己宣布这才是他的目标。这就好比所有东西都在同一个屋檐下。他的基线生成器、鼓点生成器、旋律音序器，所有这些都用粗电线连接在一起，隐藏在工厂的混凝土墙后面。当雷蒙德走到门口时，我遇到的第一件事就是，好吧，我要你签一份保密协议。汤姆·雷（Tom Ray）。他曾在穆格（Moog）工作，这可能是史上最著名的合成器公司。他曾在伯克利音乐学院教授电子音乐史，当时他是一名教授。但在
time he met Scott in the summer of 1970, he was a graduate student, working on his dissertation for a PhD in music. I mean, I'm not an industrial spy, I'm a graduate student. Ray had heard that Scott was touched with genius, and he wanted to see what he'd been inventing. What did I see? I saw everything.
1970年夏天他遇到斯科特时，他还是一名研究生，正在撰写音乐博士学位的毕业论文。我的意思是，我不是工业间谍，我是一名研究生。雷听说斯科特具有天才般的触觉，他想看看斯科特一直在发明什么。我看到了什么？我看到了所有东西。
Oh my gosh, you know, what is this thing over here? And I said, it doesn't seem to have a keyboard or any kind of an interface. He said, well, it does. It had one little micro switch. And so he goes over, and he flips some of these many, many knobs and switches and things on the panel of the thing. He said, I'm going to have it suggest a theme, and it gives out with a little melody. And then he says, I think I will ask it to make the intervals, the musical intervals wider, and he flips a couple of switches,
天哪，你知道，那边这个东西是什么？我说，它好像没有键盘或任何类型的界面。他说，嗯，它有的。它有一个微型开关。于是他走过去，在那个东西面板上的众多旋钮、开关和各种东西中拨弄了几下。他说，我要让它建议一个主题，然后它就奏出了一段小旋律。接着他说，我想让音程，也就是音乐音程变得更宽，然后他拨了几个开关，
and they're wider. You know, and he put together, as I said there, a rather lush composition with not only accompaniment, but counterpoint and the whole thing. Scott was inventing madly during those years. The Ectronium combined a lot of different gizmos he'd created and it was a constantly changing set of modules. You controlled the music the machine made by means of switches. He called the composer guidance control. One of the major x-factors of the ELECTRONIUM is that it
它们就变宽了。你知道，正如我在那里所说的那样，他拼凑出了一首相当丰富的作品，不仅有伴奏，还有对位法以及一整套东西。斯科特在那些年里疯狂地进行发明。电子琴结合了他创造的许多不同的小玩意儿，它是一个不断变化的模块组合。你通过开关来控制机器创作的音乐。他称之为作曲家引导控制（composer guidance control）。“电子琴”的一个主要未知变数是，它
seems to have had some way of generating randomness within the preset patterns. They would change on their own over time, but it's not clear to anyone how. This was a crazy idea, but you can get a clue to why Scott was after it from an ad he made around then, with Jim Henson, the Muppets guy, for IBM. They were pitching a new word processor, but the ad is all about modern life. It's a kind of crazy montage of vacant looking people, machines, and explosions. There always seem to be enough time to do the paperwork. What? Today? There isn't. Today, there isn't enough time. Today, there aren't enough people.
似乎在预设的模式中具有某种生成随机性的方式。它们会随着时间自行改变，但没人清楚具体是怎么做到的。这是一个疯狂的想法，但你可以从他当时为IBM拍摄的一则广告中窥见斯科特追求这个的原因，广告合作者是布偶创作者吉姆·汉森（Jim Henson）。他们当时在推销一种新的文字处理器，但广告的核心全关于现代生活。这是一个近乎疯狂的蒙太奇，充满了表情空洞的人、机器和爆炸。总是有足够的时间来做文书工作。什么？今天？没有。今天，没有足够的时间。今天，没有足够的人。
Machines should do their work. That's what their best path is. People should do the thinking. That's what their best path is. But what about a machine that did the work and the thinking? When Scott was born, machines were being created mostly to help people do road physical labor. In the first half of the 20th century, they began to do those things automatically at the push of a button. And by the age of the electronic, machines began automatically to do things that looked a lot like intellectual labor. This robot manipulator can be easily taught because of its electronic brain. Things began automatically to do things that looked a lot like intellectual labor. In that light, Scott was reaching for the brass ring.
机器应该去做它们的工作。那是它们最擅长的途径。人们应该去思考。那是他们最擅长的途径。但是，如果有一种既能干活又能思考的机器呢？斯科特出生时，机器的创造主要是为了帮助人们进行繁重的体力劳动。在20世纪上半叶，它们开始在按下一个按钮时自动完成这些事情。而在电子琴的时代，机器开始自动完成看起来非常像脑力劳动的任务。这种机器人机械手因为有了电子大脑，可以很容易地被教会。事情开始自动进行，看起来非常像脑力劳动。有鉴于此，斯科特正在争取最高荣誉。
A machine capable of making art, of helping people make art, that expressed a human soul, and stirred human emotions. But he needed money to do it. So he started doing a little press, small articles here and there. It's like inventing the typewriter, he told a journalist, only the typewriter furnishes the plot and reads the result. I've always told people that I consider Raymond Scott one of the pioneers of artificial intelligence in music. But if you wanted to buy an electronium from Raymond Scott, it was going to cost you an arm and a leg. And it was a crazy idea. So it was by a stroke of luck that the head of Motown Records, Barry Gordy, heard about it. It's not a one man old innovation, or two man old innovation, but it is an over-the-vation of teamwork.
一台能够创作艺术、帮助人们创作艺术、表达人类灵魂并激发出人类情感的机器。但他需要钱来完成这件事。于是他开始做一点媒体宣传，到处发一些小文章。这就像发明打字机一样，他告诉一位记者，只不过是打字机提供情节并读出结果。我一直告诉人们，我认为雷蒙德·斯科特是音乐领域人工智能的先驱之一。但如果你想从雷蒙德·斯科特那里买一台电子琴，那将会花掉你一大笔钱。这是一个疯狂的想法。因此，摩城唱片（Motown Records）的负责人巴里·戈迪（Barry Gordy）听说了这件事，纯属机缘巧合。这不是一个人的旧创新，或两个人的旧创新，而是团队合作的超越创新。
I mean, it's unseen heroes, sort of speak. Barry Gordy founded Motown in 1959 in Detroit. Before founding the company, he had worked at a car factory. During the years when there was lots of hubbub over plants that had achieved near-full automation. It was on the assembly line that Gordy started to think about doing music differently. In his autobiography, he wrote, at the plant,
我的意思是，可以说是幕后英雄。巴里·戈迪于1959年在底特律创立了摩城唱片。在创立该公司之前，他曾在一家汽车工厂工作。当时正值人们对实现近乎全自动化的工厂议论纷纷的年代。正是在装配线上，戈迪开始思考如何用不同的方式做音乐。他在自传中写道，在工厂里，
the cars started out as just a frame, pulled along on conveyor belts until they emerged at the end of the line. I wanted the same concept for my company, only with artists and songs and records. If we had, if we hadn't gone any year without, hit records would have been out of business. Motown was a black-owned business, with artists and songs and records. Motown was a black-owned business, selling music by black artists to everyone in America.
汽车最初只是一个车架，在传送带上被拉着走，直到在流水线尽头出现。我希望我的公司也有同样的理念，只不过对象换成了艺术家、歌曲和唱片。如果我们度过任何一年没有热门唱片，我们就会破产。摩城唱片是一家黑人拥有的企业，拥有艺术家、歌曲和唱片。摩城唱片是一家黑人拥有的企业，向全美国的每一个人销售黑人艺术家的音乐。
Like everything in the music business, it was precarious economically, because hit records deal in matters of taste, and taste is subject to biases and whims. Gordy, with his assembly line passed, wasn't having that. He wanted to systematize as much as possible. They'd A.B. test songs with different artists until something stuck, like R&D. They had a house band, the funk brothers, providing iron-clad rhythm section arrangements
就像音乐界的一切一样，它在经济上是不稳定的，因为热门唱片涉及品味问题，而品味受到偏见和奇思妙想的影响。戈迪有着流水线的工作经历，可不接受这一点。他希望尽可能地将流程系统化。他们会用不同的艺术家对歌曲进行A/B测试，直到有什么东西火起来，就像研发（R&D）一样。他们有一支专属乐队——放克兄弟（The Funk Brothers），为摩城唱片的所有歌曲提供坚如磐石的节奏部编排，
across Motown songs, as if they were the engine department. The only thing missing was the automation. And that's why it makes sense to me that one day in the early 1970s, Barry Gordy pulled up to Raymond Scott's warehouse with a string of limos to see the automatic songwriting machine for himself. And by the way, Barry Gordy knew who Raymond Scott was like anybody of his generation. Raymond Scott was a famous person. So Gordy also knew he Scott was, like anybody of his generation. Raymond Scott was a famous person. So Gordy also knew he was getting that in the deal.
仿佛他们就是发动机部门。唯一缺少的只有自动化。这就是为什么在我看来，20世纪70年代初的一天，巴里·戈迪开着一串豪华轿车来到雷蒙德·斯科特的仓库，亲自查看这台自动作曲机，是如此合乎情理。顺便说一句，像他那个时代的任何人一样，巴里·戈迪知道雷蒙德·斯科特是谁。雷蒙德·斯科特是个大名人。所以戈迪也知道，他
Someone who was a musical mind who has already written hits. Scott showed Gordy and his crew the warehouse. And then he fired up the electronic, just like he did with Ray. He must have shown Gordy how you flipped the switches to set a pattern. Then watched as the machine iterated, changing notes repeating phrases, rifling through ideas semi-randomly. Scott was selling an idea at that point. The potential of a songwriting machine that could hit on an idea that a person alone
能得到这样一个在交易中拥有音乐头脑、并且已经写出过热门歌曲的人。斯科特向戈迪和他的随行人员展示了仓库。然后他启动了电子琴，就像他向雷展示的那样。他一定向戈迪展示了如何拨动开关来设定音轨。然后看着机器进行迭代，改变音符、重复乐段、半随机地翻找各种想法。当时斯科特正在推销一个理念。一台有潜力碰撞出独行之人绝无可能想到的灵感的作曲机的潜力。
never would. If it came up with a hook that sparked in the way a hit does, you'd know it when you heard it, and you could bottle it up and sell it to millions of people. This idea, I think, came straight from Scott's Quintet days, finding that sound that you like the first time you hear it. It's a tricky balancing act, because it has to be new enough that it catches your attention, but a hit also has to sound familiar enough that you kind of know what you're gonna get as soon as you hear it. It's like an elevator pitch to the listener, and Gordy was uncompromising about it. Here's Smokey Robinson, in a 2019 documentary,
如果它想出了一个像热门歌曲那样能擦出火花的精彩音钩（hook），你一听就会知道，然后你就可以把它打包卖给数百万人。这个想法，我认为直接源于斯科特五重奏时期的经历，也就是找到你一听就喜欢的声音。这是一个微妙的平衡过程，因为它必须足够新颖以吸引你的注意力，但一首歌要成为热门，也必须足够耳熟，让你一听到就知道会听到什么。这就像是对听众的电梯演讲（elevator pitch），而戈迪对此毫不妥协。这是斯莫基·罗宾逊（Smokey Robinson）在2019年的一部纪录片中，
remembering that process. He was to say that all the time, we got to get him in the first 10 seconds. We wish he'd got to go to his fabulous intros. You know, something that would catch your attention immediately. So, in that light, the electronic makes perfect sense to me. What if you could take a machine that had baked into it all of the patterns and intuitive musical sense
回忆那个过程。他总是这么说，我们必须在前十秒抓住他们。我们希望他能创作他那些美妙的引子。你知道，那种能立即抓住你注意力的东西。所以，从这个角度来看，电子琴对我和说完全说得通。如果你能拥有一台融入了所有模式和直观音乐感觉的机器，会怎么样呢？
of a proven hitmaker like Scott? but then this crazy X-factor of proto-art officially intelligent randomness. That dream was Scott's life's work. He needed it to work. Everything was riding on it. So, Gordy was so impressed that you wrote a check on the spot for $10,000 to get started. And that was a lot of money back then. It was a huge windfall. Scott was overjoyed.
比如像斯科特这样战绩辉煌的热门制造者？但随后又加入了这种疯狂的未知变数——原始人工智能式的随机性。那个梦想是斯科特毕生的心血。他需要它成功。一切都押在这上面了。所以，戈迪印象极其深刻，当场就开了一张1万美元的支票作为启动资金。在当时那可是一大笔钱。这是一笔巨大的意外之财。斯科特欣喜若狂。
Gordy wanted the instrument remade to suit Motown's needs, so Scott began work immediately. The machine would be a culmination of everything he'd worked on up to that point, including the player piano from his childhood. Here's a call from a couple years earlier between Scott and Bob Mogue, the synthesizer legend who'd worked with him. And this knocked me out when I first heard it in the archives, but he was still thinking about the player piano. You can hear the ideas just bursting out of him. I have some things that I think have left me slip you.
戈迪希望这台乐器能按照摩城唱片的需求重新制作，于是斯科特立刻开始工作。这台机器将是他迄今为止所有工作成果的结晶，包括他童年时期的自动钢琴（player piano）。这是几年前斯科特和鲍勃·穆格（Bob Moog）之间的一段通话，穆格是曾与他合作过的合成器传奇人物。当我第一次在档案里听到这段时，我被深深地震撼了，但他当时仍在考虑自动钢琴。你能听到各种想法从他脑海中迸发出来。我有些东西，我想我应该让你看看。
And this is hardly secret stuff. But, well, he often does play with you when I see it. Okay. But the program here isn't evidentable. I mean, it's a computing machine to program me things. The program here is programming things. And all the automated tools to program me things. The play piano is programming things and all the automated tools are programming things. Yeah. And so the programming is, it's going to be the way it's done.
这可不是什么秘密。但是，嗯，我看到的时候他经常和你一起演奏。好的。但这里的程序是可展现的。我的意思是，这是一台用来编程事物的计算机。这里的程序正在对事物进行编程。以及所有用来编程事物的自动化工具。自动钢琴正在对事物进行编程，所有的自动化工具都在对事物进行编程。是的。所以编程就是，它将以这种方式完成。
A player piano for the space age. Scott, of course, quickly blew through the Motown down payment and ran out of time, but Gordy didn't seem to mind. Scott moved out to Motown's offices in Los Angeles to work on the Electronium in a room above Barry Gordy's garage. He became the director of electronic music, research, and development. Eventually, he started to work on the machine
属于太空时代的自动钢琴。当然，斯科特很快就花光了摩城唱片的首付款，时间也用完了，但戈迪似乎并不介意。斯科特搬到了洛杉矶的摩城唱片办公室，在巴里·戈迪车库上方的房间里研究电子琴。他成为了电子音乐研究与开发总监。最终，他开始在
in the Motown Studios. People were in awe of him. I'm thinking of a couple different engineers who were up there who would just come out and be like shaking their heads, kind of like you know what is going on kind of thing. Scott's daughter, Deb Studebaker again. According to a former engineer at Motown, Michael Jackson would come by Scott's studio, a small room on the second floor, and watch the electronic work. He made music unlike anything they'd heard. The idea wasn't that the machine
摩城唱片的录音室里研究这台机器。人们对他的才华惊叹不已。我想起几个曾在那里工作的不同工程师，他们走出来时只是直摇摇头，那种表情就像是你懂的，到底在搞什么鬼的那种状态。再次引用斯科特的女儿黛布·斯图德贝克（Deb Studebaker）的话。据摩城唱片的一位前工程师透露，迈克尔·杰克逊（Michael Jackson）曾来到斯科特位于二楼的小房间工作室，观看电子琴的工作过程。他创作的音乐是他们从未听过的。这个想法并不是指机器
would write a complete song structure, verse chorus bridge, but that it would iterate on combinations of rhythm, chord and melody, in search of that spark. It was a way of automating the part of songwriting Scott excelled at, the thing that caught your ear, and made you like something the first time you heard it. It was meant as a collaboration between man and machine, one that took the hard work out of the most crucial part of the songwriting process. The inspiration. But over time, the extreme cost weighed the project down, but also the fact that Scott was never satisfied,
会写出完整的歌曲结构（主歌、副歌、桥段），而是在节奏、和弦和旋律的组合上进行迭代，以寻找那个灵感的火花。这是一种将斯科特最擅长的部分——那个抓住你的耳朵、让你一听就喜欢的元素——进行自动化的方式。它旨在成为人与机器之间的合作，将最关键的音乐创作过程中的体力活省去。那就是灵感。但随着时间的推移，极高的成本拖累了这个项目，而且斯科特从来没有满足过，
refused to be finished. The electronic worked. It just was always opened up being redesigned, refined, changed. At one point, that same engineer tried to get Motown's famous session musicians to play along with the machine, as part of a drive to use the instrument on a recording, but they revolted. They didn't like it. They didn't like the idea of it. They didn't like the concept, they didn't like what it theoretically represented. And these guys were great musicians. They didn't want to be replaced by a machine. It's not known whether the electronic ever suggested an idea that made it into a Motown song,
拒绝宣告完成。电子琴是能正常工作的。只是它总是处于被重新设计、改进和修改的状态。有一次，同一位工程师试图让摩城著名的录音室乐手们配合机器演奏，作为在录音中使用该乐器的努力的一部分，但他们反叛了。他们不喜欢它。他们不喜欢这个想法。他们不喜欢这个概念，他们不喜欢它在理论上所代表的东西。而这些人都是伟大的音乐家。他们不想被机器取代。目前尚不清楚电子琴是否真的曾提供过最终进入摩城唱片歌曲的灵感，
but I think it's unlikely. Gordy, let's go take the electronic home with him eventually, the tinker with it around the house. He'd stay up all night and work on it all day in his pajamas, building new bits and pieces, taking it apart, and building it again. Then his health got worse. The music industry moved on, started to forget about him. He had several strokes, and the electronic him sat, and the guest shed out back, gathering dust, waiting to be found.
但我认为可能性不大。戈迪最终还是让电子琴跟他回家了，以便在家里鼓捣它。他会通宵达旦地熬夜，穿着睡衣整天摆弄它，组装新的零部组件，拆卸它，然后再组装起来。然后他的健康状况恶化了。音乐界向前发展，开始遗忘他。他中风了好几次，电子琴就这样闲置在后面的客用小屋里，积满灰尘，等待着被人发现。
Well, it's Dr. Frankenstein's monster, isn't it? Brian Ki-Hue again, synthesizer wizard, former keyboardist for the who, Fiona Apple producer, and the second person this episode to bring up Frankenstein's monster, more happily in this case, about a machine rather than a person. He's working now to bring the electronic back to life. We spoke last winter. And so, electronic might be literally just a piece of inspiration. If I play piano or if I play guitar and write songs, my fingers are even limiting because I tend to play a certain chord shape
嗯，这就是弗兰肯斯坦的怪物，不是吗？再次引用布赖恩·基-休（Brian Kehew）的话，他是合成器奇才、The Who乐队前键盘手、菲奥娜·苹果（Fiona Apple）的制作人，也是本集中第二个提起弗兰肯斯坦怪物的人，不过在这个案例中，他更多是高兴地将它与机器而非人联系起来。他现在正致力于让电子琴复活。我们去年冬天谈过。所以，电子琴可能字面意思上就只是一个灵感来源。如果我弹钢琴或弹吉他写歌，我的手指甚至是一种限制，因为我倾向于弹奏某种特定的和弦指法，
where I'm jazzier and he's more country. But if the electronic was not confined by those things, it might come up with ideas that are beautiful hybrids. Maybe Lil Jazzy but Lil Pocca. And who knows what it would come up with. But that's an idea to say that the human creativity is limited. It's a beautiful thing when it works, but as we know, you can't just write great musical day, otherwise everybody would.
而我更偏向爵士风格，他则更偏向乡村风格。但如果电子琴不受这些东西的约束，它可能会想出一些美丽的杂交创意。也许有点爵士味，又带点波卡（Polka）味。谁知道它会想出什么呢。但这是一个观点，说明人类的创造力是有限的。当它奏效时，这是一件美妙的事情，但正如我们所知，你不能只是每天都写出伟大的音乐，否则每个人都能做到。
I guess part of the problem is like in a creative line of work, your business, especially when you're a Motown, which is an empire at that point, is totally dependent on this fundamentally unknowable, unreliable thing, which is human creativity. Like you never really know when the music is going to strike. And so, especially with the kind of assembly line, Motown idea, if you could just make that predictable and automate it, the aha moment, then that would take a lot of the uncertainty out of the business. I think you pointed out something that most people don't want to ever mention, which is that creativity is unreliable.
我想问题的一部分在于，就像在创意行业中一样，你的业务——特别是当你身处摩城唱片这样一个当时堪称帝国的机构时——完全依赖于这种根本不可知、不可靠的东西，那就是人类的创造力。就像你永远不知道灵感什么时候会降临。因此，尤其是对于流水线式的摩城理念来说，如果你能让“啊哈！”的灵感时刻变得可预测并实现自动化，那么就会消除业务中的很多不确定性。我认为你指出了一点大多数人从不愿意提及的事情，那就是创造力是不可靠的。
You might be Paul McCartney and able to write some of the world's greatest songs, but if I brought him in the room right now and gave him an hour said, write me a great song, it doesn't work that way. It doesn't work that way, but you can understand why someone who devoted his whole life to making perfect music, wish that it did. Raymond Scott died in 1994 in obscurity and relative poverty in a nursing home near that faded house in Van Nies. Choose a winner, a slew of fellow enthusiasts, and the Scott family started to comb through his archives to piece the whole crazy story together. They shipped boxes and boxes of tapes and records and papers to the Mar Sound Archives at the University of Missouri Kansas City. Then they released his music
你可能是保罗·麦卡特尼（Paul McCartney），能够写出世界上最伟大的几首歌曲，但如果我现在把他带进房间给他一个小时说，给我写一首伟大的歌，事情不是那样运作的。事情不是那样运作的，但你可以理解为什么一个毕生致力于创作完美音乐的人，会希望事情是那样的。雷蒙德·斯科特于1994年在范奈司那栋褪色房屋附近的一家疗养院里默默无闻、相对贫困地去世了。丘斯·威纳（Choose Winner）、一群狂热爱好者以及斯科特家族开始翻找他的档案，把这个疯狂的故事拼凑起来。他们把一箱又一箱的磁带、唱片和文件运往密苏里大学堪萨斯城分校的马尔声音档案馆（ Marr Sound Archives）。然后他们发布了他的音乐
in compilations. Scott had always kept his machines mostly secret in case anyone wanted to steal them. But when they finally released Scott's electronic music in the early 2000s, he suddenly had a new set of posthumous hits. You probably don't even realize you've heard a raiment Scott's song before, but he's been sampled all over the place. Gorillas, Jay Dilla, Lizzo, they've all sampled Scott. His music is in the Simpsons, Rennon Stimpy, HBO shows. The song you're hearing now is called Portofino, and it was unreleased in his lifetime.
合辑。斯科特过去总是把他的机器严加保密，以防有人偷走它们。但当他们在2000年代初终于发布斯科特的电子音乐时，他突然迎来了一批新的死后热门歌曲。你可能甚至没有意识到自己以前听过雷蒙德·斯科特的歌，但他的音乐被到处采样。Gorillaz、J Dilla、Lizzo，都采样过斯科特。他的音乐出现在《辛普森一家》、《莱恩和史丁比》以及HBO的节目中。你现在听到的这首歌叫《波托菲诺》（Portofino），在他生前并未发行。
But there are all these recordings of it, each trying it a different way. All electronics, with vocals, with saxophone. When the archivists found it, choose it thought the melody was so classic, it must have been a cover. And I went into various databases looking for Portofino, like just like 80 or 100 things called Portofino. And I would go through iTunes and listen to every goddamn one of them and not one of them was Raymond's Melody.
但有所有这些关于它的录音，每段都尝试了不同的方式。有纯电子的、有人声的、有萨克斯的。当档案管理员发现它时，丘斯觉得这段旋律太经典了，一定是一首翻唱歌曲。我进入了各种数据库寻找《波托菲诺》，就像找了大约80或100首叫《波托菲诺》的东西一样。我会浏览iTunes并听完每一个该死的版本，结果没有一个是雷蒙德的旋律。
But to this date, I mean, that thing's been out for 21 years. No one has come to us and said, hmm, that's cover version, or someone else wrote that, or it's a traditional melody. A true original. Meanwhile, Mark Mothersbaugh, the lead singer of Divo, bought the ELECTRONIUM and dragged it from the shed to his studios. Brian Ki-Hoo is trying now to assemble a team of engineers to bring it back online in digital or physical form.
但直到今天，我的意思是，那首曲子已经问世21年了。没有人来对我们说过，嗯，那是翻唱版本，或者那是别人写的，或者那是一首传统旋律。真正的原创。与此同时，Devo乐队的主唱马克·莫瑟巴赫（Mark Mothersbaugh）买下了电子琴，并把它从棚屋里拖到了自己的录音室。布赖恩·基-休现在正试图组装一个工程师团队，以数字或物理形式将其重新上线。
Even with all the schematics, they're still mystified. You know, it's somebody said it's still a black box, and that's true. We still don't know what it did, and I feel like we're looking through a keyhole at a room, and we can barely see it until we get through the door a bit more. There are Scott cover bands and Scott festivals. Somehow his music still resonates. Whatever Sparky-Cott is still catching. What I think is strange is most of the musicians who knew Scott earlier in his life seemed to have hated him, but the engineers who knew him at the end of his life loved him. A lot of his early jazz hits were aggressive, frantic firecrackers of song, but the electronic
尽管拥有所有的原理图，他们仍然感到迷惑不解。你知道，有人说它依然是一个黑匣子，确实如此。我们仍然不知道它是如何运作的，我觉得我们就像是在透过钥匙孔窥视一个房间，在真正穿过这扇门之前，我们只能勉强看到一点点。现在有斯科特的翻唱乐队，也有斯科特音乐节。不知何故，他的音乐依然产生着共鸣。无论Sparky-Scott捕捉到的是什么。我觉得奇怪的是，大多数在斯科特生前认识他的音乐家似乎都讨厌他，但那些在他生命尽头认识他的工程师却很喜欢他。他的许多早期爵士乐热门单曲都是富有攻击性、狂热激昂的音乐爆竹，但电子琴的
stuff is often sweet, guileless, innocent. Some of that stuff was written in partnership with the electronic him. His melody, its patterns. And it sounds like a songwriter at peace with himself. At one point he'd resisted human control of it, but then he took one of the voice cards and adapted it to a keyboard input. As he found before when he would put a Hammond organ or a mostly an Ande lane on top of the electronic him, it really needed somebody doing a nice melody in order to sell the package. There is, I think, a lesson in Scott's life. One that's kind of a morality tale for our own AI-addled chat GPT world.
作品通常甜美、率真、天真。其中一些作品是与电子琴合作创作的。他的旋律，加上它的音轨模式。这听起像是一位与自己达成内心的音乐家。有一段时间，他曾抗拒人类对其的控制，但后来他采用了其中一张语音卡，将其适配到了键盘输入上。正如他以前发现的那样，当他在电子琴上叠加一把哈蒙德风琴（Hammond organ）或一架安德莱恩（Andelane）时，它确实需要有人弹奏一首优美的旋律来推销整个作品。我认为，斯科特的生平中蕴含着一个教训。这是一个对我们这个被人工智能困扰的ChatGPT世界而言带有某种道德寓意的故事。
He walked from automatic pianos to the first computers. He sought perfection. He sought industrial scale creativity. But the trade-offs he made were the relationships around him. The failure to see the humanity of the people he was trying to control. People would sometimes talk about Scott as if he were a machine. But I think there's something in his music that testifies to a soul, that ghost at the keys of the player piano. Those recorded phone calls to his family, federally string of hits, all the musical machines.
他从自动钢琴一路走到第一台计算机。他追求完美。他追求工业规模的创造力。但他所做出的权衡是他周围的人际关系。他未能看到他试图控制的人们的共同人性。人们有时谈论斯科特时，仿佛他是一台机器。但我认为他的音乐中有些东西证明了灵魂的存在，那个自动钢琴琴键后面的幽灵。那些打给家人的录音电话、源源不断的热门歌曲、所有的音乐机器。
What they have in common is the goal of each song, to connect people through sound. Scott prized perfection in that end, above everything else, and it ruined him. Someday soon someone might be able to bring the electronic back to life, and here again the inside of Scott's mind. But still, I think he must have known. The electronic could never write a Raymond Scott song. For that, you needed Raymond Scott. The last archive is written and hosted by me, Ben Nadefafri.
它们的共同点是每首歌曲的目标，都是通过声音将人们连接起来。为此，斯科特将完美置于一切之上，而这毁了他。不久的将来，也许有人能够让电子琴复活，并再次倾听斯科特内心的想法。不过，我想他一定心知肚明。电子琴永远无法写出一首雷蒙德·斯科特的歌。要做到这一点，你需要雷蒙德·斯科特。本期《最后的档案》（The Last Archive）由我本·纳达夫-阿夫里（Ben Nadef-Afri）撰写并主持。
It's produced by me and Lucy Sullivan, and edited by Sophie Crane. Jake Gorsky is our engineer. Fact checking on this episode by Arthur Gomperts and Lucy Sullivan. Sound design by Jake Gorsky and Lucy Sullivan. Our executive producers are Sophie Crane and Jill LePore. Thanks also to Julia Barton, Pushkin's executive editor, Original Music by Matthias Bossy and John Evans of Stellwagen Symphonet. Additional Music by Corn Tooth. Our foolproof player is Becca A. Lewis. Many of our sound effects are from Harry Jeanette Jr. in the Star Jeanette Foundation. Special thanks on this episode to Alan W. Entenment, Jack Hertz, Carl Miller and the
本节目由我和露西·沙利文（Lucy Sullivan）制作，苏菲·克兰（Sophie Crane）编辑。杰克·戈尔斯キー（Jake Gorsky）担任我们的工程师。本集的核查人员为亚瑟·戈姆珀茨（Arthur Gomperts）和露西·沙利文。声音设计由杰克·戈尔斯キー和露西·沙利文共同完成。我们的执行制片人是苏菲·克兰和吉尔·莱波雷（Jill Lepore）。同时感谢朱莉娅·巴顿（Julia Barton），普希金（Pushkin）执行编辑，原创音乐由斯特尔瓦根交响网（Stellwagen Symphonette）的马蒂亚斯·博西（Matthias Bossy）和约翰·埃文斯（John Evans）创作。附加音乐由Corn Tooth提供。我们的防错播放器是贝卡·A·莱维斯（Becca A. Lewis）。我们的许多音效来自让-杰内基金会（Star Jeanette Foundation）的小哈里·让内特（Harry Jeanette Jr.）。特别感谢本集的艾伦·W·恩滕曼（Alan W. Entenment）、杰克·赫茨（Jack Hertz）、卡尔·米勒（Carl Miller）及庇里牛斯录音协会（Pyrean Recording Society）和拜伦·维纳（Byron Werner）。
Pyrean Recording Society, and Byron Werner. For a bibliography further reading and a transcript and teaching guide to this episode, head to thelastarchive.com. The Last Archive is a production of Pushkin Industries. I'm Ben Nathafri. free. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
有关本集的参考书目、延伸阅读、文字记录和教学指南，请访问thelastarchive.com。《最后的档案》是普希金工业公司（Pushkin Industries）出品的节目。我是本·纳达夫-阿夫里。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。